good morning Millennials happy Thursday
welcome Gary thank you once twice three
times a co-host actually four times the
co-host of you can if you count the
first time that we co-hosted together
back in February yes that was that was
on the breath yeah yeah that was on the
breath this is for fourth time is that
for us Wow because we were making a big
deal tangles from southern charm
Savannah was younger on Tuesday and he
is our first ever three-time guest and
you're our fourth time co-host that's
big stuff you guys that's huge I feel
like I should be on a wall so we're
gonna do like a wall of fame yeah today
it couldn't be a better day everyone has
been waiting for this day this episode
specifically I remember back in February
when this all went down we reported the
news yep that there were rumors that the
women of Real Housewives of New York
we're on a sinking ship literally in
Cartagena and I couldn't wrap my head
around like what that would look like
yeah and you came on and you told us
like it's crazy you said this season is
crazy but after the season before I was
like how crazy could it be and I
obviously had no [ __ ] clue because
this is the best season of a Real
Housewives franchise
wow you think 1000% the past three
episodes like even if one of the fights
of last night's episode it was just one
of them like that would have made for an
episode of Beverly Hills like this has
been and you know it's a true testament
when it's like one episode is just one
day it's right there trying to show us
as much as possible which I so I feel
like we really are getting the full
picture and that really so much is
happening and when you have a table of
women and like there's a fight at one
end there's a fight at the other end and
then there's Sonja Tinsley kissing in
the middle I just think that qualifies
like carta Hania is on par with scary
island definitely I think this is gonna
go down and infamy on par with Alison du
Bois your husband will never emotionally
fulfill you while smoking her Issei Yeah
right obviously he six like I feel like
they their stock went down after that
episode but now they're back up with the
jewel yeah to rebrand oh is it Allison
du Bois
that's fair cuz she also looked very bad
smoking me he's like she wasn't smoking
in like the cool way you can smoke and
he say no she was smoking and I can
evil which sort of way yes and then
there's like the Dorinda LuAnn subplot
because it's really Bethany encounter
but like this is also a big friendship I
don't think people realize like how much
Dorinda was there for Lynne like when it
was saying that I was understanding what
she was saying just her message was
delivered in a horrible way therefore
definitely all credibility is lost
I mean German has been there for
everybody I think over the years like
she has that potential to be of super
warmint but you know the drinking
doesn't help anybody it's like
sensitivities no yeah so anyways we were
gonna we are gonna break down all of
last night's episode later on in the
show so that we can go forever and we're
gonna have to talk about because that
summer I was on I said I was team Carol
yes and I got a lot of flack for it
including your shady eyes well so we'll
have to we'll have to digest that bad
when you said that it was a 50-50
audience why so like right I was curious
as to hear your side of the story but
you know things have changed now yes
they have and I feel vindicated okay
word to hearing your rebuttal yes yes
yes we will robot yes yes but for and we
have just so many Bravo related
questions for you I literally made so
many notes cuz like so much is popping
on right now so many rumors are swirling
yep in the Bravo world and we're gonna
get to all of that okay good good it
always leads back to Bravo as we say it
always leads back to Bravo and speaking
of we have confirmation that Annie knows
about the morning toast can you
elaborate Annie knows about the morning
toast he is he's on top of all this
stuff whenever I guests appear or any
any where like he pays attention he
likes he's like low-key you know what's
about it you know what I mean he said
you heard it here first he low-key but I
think he's ever like hey Darren like
what's the morning toast what's the best
way for me to understand like what these
I'm gonna say come on in the show and
see come on the show and see or he can
listen to our 45-minute Real Housewives
of New York recap from last week where
we literally we were sweating talking
going in talked about Bethenny and
Carole like really trying to get to the
bottom of their relationship and I
really feel like that we did I see you
and Claudia just like having blueprints
and like notes and stacks of everything
you've taken over the years and been
like episode 2 season 1 this happened
totally we're like cheater brands yeah
no it's like that mean where it's like
me trying to figure out like where my
man is it's like the whole board that's
us the coordinates you guys got the
whole thing we got
whole thing but before we get into the
whole thing yeah we are here to hit you
with the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast I'm ready
a wide array of stories obviously you
know there's Megan Marco um but there's
a lot else going on in the world and
I've really been trying to evolve
towards like not just talking about PTIN
Arianna Grande
do you like Megan Markel overall yes I
think that she is incredible like what
the fact that she went from like being
on hallmark right to being like to
living out a hallmark movie is
everything to me totally like I don't
agree with most of her style choices and
I just like wish she would step it up in
that department and I don't I don't
understand how she can be wearing
ill-fitting clothes when like she must
have a tailor like she has a must have
she was a 85 tailors for each seat like
she must have someone who like does up
the back of her dress every morning
right yes so I don't understand how that
keeps happening okay
but I love that we have an American in
there and it's just so culturally
relevant and overall I love it I just
did you watch suits now okay so you just
love her as like the story of her this
story of her dealer No Deal lest we
forget yes and I love hallmark like home
our Christmas movies the whole shebang I
need to be in a hallmark movie that's
like my actual one of my goals in life
is to be in a home are for me because I
like such a Hallmark face and vibes do
you really do actually like redheads has
leads like I really think I could do it
except for the fact that I'm a horrible
actress no that doesn't matter that and
I hope but then I also feel like acting
is sort of like I think yeah it's like
your whole life is a rom-com Jackie
you're gonna be fine
totally yeah so for the hallmark of it
all I love Megan okay Marco okay that's
fair um actually you know what that's
great so our second stories about her
when I bump it up to number one do it
page six is reporting that Megan Markel
is being kept at a distance from the
media a royal correspondent is claiming
journalists are allegedly being kept at
a distance from the Dutchess of Sussex
Megan Marco during official engagements
so that they can't overhear any remarks
that may breach royal protocol Richard
Palmer a reporter for London's Daily
Express who has covered the former sued
stars appearances made the claim on
Twitter Tuesday in a series of tweets
quote railroaded journalists are
kept further away from her than we were
before the wedding he claimed that means
we can't hear what she is saying if you
can't get direct quotes from members of
the royal family that often makes for
dull stories you go afterwards and ask
what she said
mr. blog said the Duchess expressed the
hope that women would eventually get the
same opportunities as men in this
profession boring in what profession and
in the profession of being royal yeah
I'm not really sure that that we're
counting that as a person you get paid
to be a royal uh I guess you get a
paycheck
I don't think so cuz I think you just
get like free your life is funded by the
taxpayers right exactly so payment
enough really that's it's more than
enough yeah so just as Kate Middleton
that inevitably leaves you with little
else to write about except what she wore
and looked like these stories have
limited shelf life okay I actually
understand both sides of this like yeah
break it cuz I don't remember Kate
minami because she's British and so
therefore it's like the American and
Megan Marco where she was like being
held from press or they couldn't handle
it I think everyone's kind of scared of
how Megan Mark was gonna like react in
public yeah I don't know why that is is
that an American thing I think I don't
know I think maybe it's just like you
wouldn't go from like Deal or No Deal to
like the most famous family in the world
but it's a different level of press and
attention fare so but I feel like she
was born for this like she carries
herself so well she like always wanted
to be famous clearly so like this is
Fame at its finest
I mean she's half black she's a divorcee
she was like taking pictures as like a
14 year old girl in front of Buckingham
Palace like 15 years ago let's give this
girl a break like this girl made made a
tree made huge
she literally broke through three of the
most major things to become this like
royal no I gave it up to her I give it
up to her too but what's weird is like
it seems as though they don't want the
press quoting what she's saying at
events but she is very well-spoken and
even before she met Harry like she used
to do a lot of speaking engagements
there are all these quotes of like
repressive things that she said so I
feel like if anyone is capable of
speaking to the press it would be her
yeah as far as I knew Kate had no formal
training I mean I don't know how you
become when you marry like a prince like
you must go through some type of media
training but she wasn't no but I feel
like
whole life was training like like she
she went she came out of the womb like
this she was in the right schools like
met will at such a young age that like
she was always like programmed to be a
royal you know I think it's the American
thing like no one trusts Megan for like
she's like crass and she's you know her
dad isn't setting a good precedent know
that whole family I just think she
started like started off on the wrong
foot not necessarily because of her but
just the press warming it they got
married so quickly I think for the
general population it just wasn't a good
start it wasn't easy start and I feel
like also she might be really
overwhelmed like you know wouldn't you
like and especially with her family like
just being out there like dragging her
through the mud
I think she might like need to be taking
like a backseat while also being very
public definitely I agree so I
understand the Royal Family's decision
and I look forward to seeing it on the
crown that's literally all I can think
about and I think I'm actually what's
gonna play out I'm like season five
season five in eight years and I'm
actually the most patient person on the
planet like when we were telling that
story about the boat in carta honey like
it was like I didn't mean further
details like I will wait until the
episode comes out right and here we are
pieces unfold like in a scripted show I
guess and scripted and it's bait like
Rurouni is the reality of yeah and the
crown is really based in reality so once
they're ready to tell me they're I'm
never gonna get answers now because it's
all happening now they're gonna not
gonna let me like see how the sauce is
made of course but eventually when they
are like you know Prince George is
getting married and his kids are being
wild no one will care what Meghan Markel
did in 2018 when she's 95 no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] and then we'll find out the
real truth here right get me know what I
am patient and how odd this next story
is really sad but sort of exciting
bittersweet news okay Anthony Bourdain's
parts unknown will return for a final
season this fall following the tragic
death of Anthony Bourdain his signature
show will carry on his legacy with one
final season nearly two months since the
61 year old star was found dead in his
hotel room in France where he was
filming for an upcoming episode of parts
unknown
Bourdain will posthumously returned to
the small screen for a 7 episode season
to debut in the fall a representative
for CNN confirmed to e news one episode
highlighting Kenya will be the last two
feet
Bourdain signature narration according
to the LA Times which recently published
an interview with Amy and Telus the
executive vice president of talent and
content at CNN for other episodes will
be finished by the directors who found
them and use audios of Bourdain captured
on location to fill the holes along with
follow-up interviews of others that's a
lot I mean listen I think there's a good
and bad thing of it you know because
it's kind of a reminder of how his
struggle like not to bring it down but
like committed suicide that's a terrible
story on the other hand it's nice to
have kind of this one final piece of him
because this show brought so like he
brought the world to us and that's
fantastic so many people weren't showing
like the Congo and what they eat there
except Anthony Bourdain so it's like
it's morbid but it's kind of nice that
we get one more chance agreed and it
just like contributes to his legacy and
I'm sure so many people like I wasn't
super familiar with his work until it
was passing so but I'm gonna watch this
now or so many more people are gonna be
introduced to his work and I think in
turn it'll actually be really nice and
it's nice that they have this this
footage it's a little eerie yes
definitely it's it's it's morbid but it
also might encourage other people to
kind of like carry that baton and
another little Bourdain who's running
around right now might be able to go to
like Vietnam and show us that and this
you know it's it's very cool it's cool
and it's cool that like we can do that
you know we don't have to like make a
hologram I'm really not here for
hologram thanks God we don't like the
first Tupac hologram was kind of dope
yeah was it like at Coachella it was
like yeah like it was well done it was
cool no one expected it now it's like
Michael Jackson's hologram going on tour
that is so weird to me
I can't where I heard like Lisa Marie
Presley wants to go potentially wants to
go on tour with a hologram of her father
Elvis like why are we doing this I don't
understand this this is weird
speaking of how did you feel about the
Prince hologram or a projection at the
Super Bowl I mean I knew it was gonna
happen because Prince is just the most
massive person ever
you know what meanest about fetch I
thought in his school
yeah it was from Minnesota uh you know I
mean it was fine I don't I was never the
biggest prints fan so for me it wasn't
like so for me was like weird he was
like his face was on a sheet and I heard
that him and Justin Timberlake like had
beef and I heard that print really like
the post post Seamus post hummus
technological versions of artists like
he already so they literally did
everything they wouldn't have wanted to
do totally and that's the part that bugs
me cuz you know you want to put your
face on the sheet like that's cool
I mean it's what I loves you and like
the Superbowl is in there the weird
thing is in their house so where they
would holograms is sometimes even though
I don't like them and I agree with you
sometimes they're better performances
and some of the pop stars out there who
just lip-sync anyway and like robots
onstage that's true so I'm like actually
it kind of is a hologram either way you
mean like Britney did you see Andy as
the victim okay good because you did it
you didn't ask that's like the first
thing people ask me like I can't believe
Andy was and like she didn't know his
name it was again Jamie Lane called her
out yep
I texted him in the morning and I was
like I think I need to quit my job
because I literally can't unsee you
crawling around with Britney whipping
your ass so as an employee yes was that
like for you it was terrifying and
exhilarating all at once I mean the
thing I knew it was happening for weeks
you did
oh yeah but he didn't know no he knew
like something was gonna happen well
have you know if it was a coincidence or
not no like my fantastic coincidence
that would be that you know where your
say I mean most of the time it's not
anybody famous so like I don't know how
that works maybe they just grabbed
someone in like the same seat but he
knew because they needed to know where
he was sitting he didn't know what to do
on stage if you can tell like he's
holding his arms up and they're just
like whispering [ __ ] in his his ear like
all the time I mean it was exciting it
was really cool to see but the fact that
she didn't know his name and she was
like oh I think you know him give it up
for him it was the funniest thing I've
ever seen in my entire life and I've
been saying it to him constantly not for
him like hey
girl singing happy birthday to someone
you're like happy birthday happy I was
exact giving up for him I died like I
thought it was the greatest thing too
and the truth is him not being able to
say like Oh Andy Cohen got it more press
anyway so it ended up being this like
huge joke that we do in absolutely we
all loved it he took it amazingly well
and like that's what's so great about
him that he would take that amazing he
would look it's like a pop culture
moment like Tony wants to be in it and
I'm sure she knew like I'm sure
thousands of people had said Andy
Cohen's coming on stage but she's
running like a huge you know she'd show
she's kind of a robot she's kind of a
robot yeah watch Heather McMahon's in
sasori's there's not there's something
going on there and there's also nothing
going on there's been a lot and nothing
going on for right quite some time
yeah yeah I don't think that's psychotic
break like ever ended I just think you
started to look more like this they just
pulled the strings tighter yeah and
she's just like yeah yeah totally so yes
I agree bad for you a hologram Mike and
I just don't understand why she can't
retire like why won't her people let her
stop working she clearly doesn't enjoy
it that much like she it seems like I've
heard weird things about her dad like
her dad controls all of her like ever
since that psychotic break like he
controls all of her finances and it's
really I don't know how much of it is
true but I've just heard there's a lot
of like controlling factors and she's
just a literally a cash machine right
like just keep performing people will
pay 300 bucks to go see her literally
lip-synch and it's like easy money
that's great it's just sad I won't and
it's sad because I feel like it's like
ruining her legacy a little bit because
she was such an icon and now it's like
so she now she's performing at Radio
City which is prestigious and my
favorite venue but it's also not the
biggest thing you should could be
performing on right and everyone thinks
she's a robot like everybody thinks
she's talking about it like I'm not even
worried this is ever gonna get back to
her because like if someone told her
like oh the morning clothes things here
or back she would be like okay yes I am
but that's my version of a robot
speaking of performances I was telling
you I saw Amy Schumer last night yes up
here 7:00
and it was amazing but I heard that
Bridget ever was opening for her and I'm
a big fan of Bridget's just from watch
what happens live I've never really seen
her do anything else except for like
roles in trainwreck and like inside Amy
Schumer yep
and she actually performed after Amy oh
she her whole it was very it was a short
set but her like her whole thing is like
she sings I guess yes she's writes
original songs she's a very buxom woman
very buxom woman I saw her boob twice Oh
once unintentionally and then once
intentionally okay yes so that was
exciting
okay I just love her so so much she is
like so funny is so many people are like
she should come a co-hosted host which I
would absolutely love but I would be so
intimidated because she's so funny you
wouldn't be able to say anything
people hosted like it would be her iPad
yeah and I would I would be an audience
member
correct correct but she was on watch
what happens live with Kelly with Kelly
like last week last week or two weeks
ago and her dress was just so short and
tight that she had her dog sitting there
I thought her lap at one point and she
lifts it off and and he's like the
control room is telling you to put the
dog back no I saw the camera kept like
moving up I was like her cooter is
definitely out just but that's her like
she's just like I've seen her at Joe's
Pub she'll just come out topless and
just suffocate you with her boobs like
it's amazing dress last night and like
her boobs fell out at one point and it
wasn't intentional I was like so nervous
I was like oh my god no one no one can
tell her it's a huge venue like it's not
intimate like right like she can't hear
a scream from the audience like boobs
out like but she that's part of she
probably knew that it was out though
right like she doesn't get it she
dressed and she was wearing had so much
like flex like it was just like don't
sometimes sometimes it would get close
sometimes not it was hilarious and I
just want to thank Bravo for introducing
me to her work you're welcome she's also
the countess and friends show she
performs you're lying I swear to God
okay now I have to see it and we also
have to talk about the countess we will
definitely okay I mean I have my notes
and moaning I'm not letting you go until
I get through all of them no this is
mean a six-hour show I'm fully aware of
the commitment okay yeah well I know I
told you I'm chained in here they don't
see it but I'm changed you can't see
anything okay
next story is actually exciting for carb
lovers Panera Bread
we'll double bread bowls just a text
test how much you love carbs so we have
a photo Panera Bread is testing this
bread bowl that's two holes so looks
like a little looks like a little canoe
almost looks like a canoe or like a
chest it looks like boobs it does yeah
uh I forget what I was gonna say that it
looks like it looks like a stuffed
potato almost okay yeah it does look
like a stuffed potatoes yeah no the
photos up on the screen and anyways I
just feel like this is so exciting
so many people love bread bowls I love
bread bowls but it does seem kind of
surprising now cuz it feels like
everyone's trying to eat it like no
bread no carbs so it feels kind of odd
the Panera would do this but cheddar
broccoli soup in a bread bowl is the
greatest thing in the world and now in a
double bread bowl we're going after this
we're gonna get a double bread I'm
unlike such a strict diet so why because
I'm getting married and because like
it's just what is the diet consists of
hello carb okay well you're not getting
a double bread bowl with me but maybe
when I hit my goal weight then we'll go
get okay yeah like celebrate yourself
yeah totally that's that's a fun goal
how far are you off from it like months
okay I know but you know I'm patient
like I said I know you're patient but
I'm not please don't want a [ __ ]
bread bowl but Jackie oh yeah I'll go
with you I don't really test my
willpower
watch me cuz I hate that smell I'll get
it I'll get the Jesse no I actually like
like yes being healthy is great the
world is taking is changing for the
better in terms of promoting like
healthier options or non-gmo no trans
fats you know what some people like to
eat fattening and they don't care and
they want good options and I like that
Panera is catering to people who don't
give an F oh yes like me and you know
the marketing is the market is opening
right up because just as corporate
America is telling us we have to eat
healthier that doesn't change how people
actually heal no I'm not healthier
because corporate America told me to I'm
eating healthier because of this they
showed the art I did I'm being real with
you guys
Amy Schumer has like a funny bit where
she was like when you're 30 and your
bridesmaid like all you want is just
like not have the fattest arm in the
group right exactly everyone's like oh
like but even if you're in the middle of
the picture I see all my friends cuz I'm
30 they'll be doing like this I'm like
you look so uncomfortable
like it looks awkward I
I'm very anti the skinny arm pose
because I feel like it actually makes
you it just makes you look insecure well
I know odd like who stands like what if
I came up no excited the entire toys
like and I actually ninja tutors who
keep your arm down have like a little
bit of Pudge and then it's like oh wow
that's what she looks like with her arm
like that's pretty good arm right I'm
like Kim K's dyskinesia she's ever been
as I'm sure you saw and she keeps giving
her arm like that I'm like girl like why
do you work so hard if you're still
gonna do your arm like that like put it
down you've earned it
and like you're gorgeous so just like on
your body like teach girls to own their
body like that's the most beautiful
thing in the world today I'm very anti
to the skinny arm you guys for a
multitude of reasons right I agree yes
but good luck on your diet we'll get
bread bowls in a few months
yeah and it's mostly like just for how I
feel and you know like yeah if I felt
great I wouldn't care but right
I don't think McDonald's stock has gone
down because corporate America is like
you can only eat kale right that's not
people are still eating the way that
they are is always eating right we were
just talking about this the Big Mac
turned 50 the other day
so we were celebrating it's the best
like I've never had one actually I've
had one in Israel because it's kosher
there did you ever see supersize me uh
yes but a really long time ago so
there's this guy that eats three Big
Macs a day he's like the skinniest
person everybody is like 120 pounds so
you don't know how in just like that's
the life that I want to live eat three
[ __ ] Big Macs a day have you seen the
founder I saw half of it I didn't finish
it with Michael Keaton right yes you
have to finish it it's next toast movie
of the week next week so oh okay good
this is much about all the toasters this
gives me time oh so toasters iron said
that you guys are the nicest people ever
oh I did I was like your fans I came in
here first thing I was like your fans
are the nicest human beings ever like
you just are so loving and I absolutely
love all of you thank you welcome and
you guys like us so we appreciate that's
right okay next up interesting news
Facebook and Instagram add dashboards to
help you manage your time spent on
social apps you can now set reminders to
tell you and you spent too much time
browsing your feeds this is okay so we
have to have an app to monitor how much
Ron apps almost right no but it's built
it's in the app so it's not a separate
app Facebook and Instagram I was just
trying to get you to understand how much
time
spending on apps which is a little scary
yeah Facebook and Instagram are
introducing a new dashboard to tell you
how long you've spent inside their apps
along with tools for setting daily
limits and temporarily muting your push
notifications the new set of feature is
called quote your time on Facebook and
quote your activity on Instagram are
designed to address the concerns that
addicted feedback loops built into
social apps have been detrimental to
users while being wow they're really
struggling like this is well this is
sort of like counterintuitive because
it's encouraging people to spend less
time on their apps but they must really
be worried about their image that they
would do something like this they I mean
wouldn't I would assume that that's the
best interest to have their customers be
on their app literally 100% why they
should fudge the numbers right and if
this is true and you guys are like gonna
start counting then just start watching
the show on YouTube so that you feel
better about it oh that's a really
that's a really good like workaround
that yeah instead of counting calories
count how many seconds you're on an app
and just go on a different app and we're
correct
yeah because toad toast isn't time spent
on social media it's it's the news no
one's counting how long you watch the
news for that's really or watch it on
other person's phone so they get the
minutes and you don't necessarily see
anything on your graph and you look at
your graph and you're like I spend one
minute on social media to make you know
we're just thinking of ways around this
I get to how much time do you think you
spend on Facebook and Instagram honestly
I don't like that's how we all
communicate so it doesn't feel like
Facebook it just feels like toe stuff
exactly it does feel like toast book I
go on there all the time just to see
legs Bend too much time on Facebook I
don't like it as much as Instagram
personally if it weren't for the morning
toasters group I would I would spend
absolutely no time on Facebook I am a
whole like if people like me or this and
that I just of the martinis and murder
which is my podcast fanpage which I
definitely a Neely type of promotion but
I'm not like reading Facebook know and
like when I see something in my feed
that's like not toast related I like
very much question if I still need to be
friends with this person and I'm just
clearing house yeah me too I'm cool it's
spring cleaning early and if I want to
like stalk someone if I'm like oh I
haven't seen my friend like Kim in a
while I go on Instagram I don't go on
Facebook which is weird does he get more
information on Facebook technically but
then if you look at my facebook page
which used to be like so vibrant like
always changed my profile picture like
worried what people are gonna think of
me
my cover photo has to complement my
profile picture right like now if you
look at my tag like I don't upload my
photos to Facebook anymore where I used
to be like the person who did me too
so now if you look at my tagged photos
it's like well that's sad
like you only went out one night in the
past six months I used to tag every
photo when I was in college I mean
granted like I'm older than you so
Facebook was like kind of just starting
to come out when I was in college I
tagged every single drunken picture of
me looking horrendous cuz that's what
you do and they see and it was cool back
then and now when I look at you know
like your memories from this day I am
utterly mortified at the things that I
would literally take time to upload onto
my face right and by proud of correct I
haven't uploaded in a crazy photo like
No all right I want you to see this
crazy phone I don't need to be looking
at myself throwing up on a Duane Reade
when I'm 20 like I think I can get rid
of that image now yeah I'm good I'm good
too yeah so I definitely spend a lot of
time on Instagram I'm not gonna I'm not
sure always professional purposes um but
maybe once they see how much time it
that actually is I mean how much card
day do you think you spend on like how
Laughton do you check your phone like
every minute yeah I probably check like
every time I get a notification I'll at
least glance over yeah the good thing is
is Instagram isn't on a desktop and I
work at a computer so I'm not it's not
like I have it on the side and it
doesn't work as well on a desktop you
need it on your phone it's literally a
mobile app the only time you like cut
back on my phone activity is when my
wrist starts to hurt like and that's and
it's real and then I'm like oh wow I
must have been on my phone a lot and a
bad day yeah so that that's been like my
timer but now I'll have a real one when
we see your graphs you have to post them
because I good I need like full jackieo
I wonder how long they've been tracking
this for us so like it does it start
tomorrow
is it being rolled out or do they have
all this like retroactive information so
yeah must have all the sources say where
do they store all this stuff because if
you think about it I don't know if this
happens on your phone like with facebook
notifications like I'll check my
notifications immediately and then like
a new notification will pop up so we
think there's like some sort of
algorithm which makes you check it
almost all the time it's not just like
getting rid of your notifications all at
once like they like store certain
notifications so they pop up on your
phone so you check it more that's so
crazy
just like let us live we're gonna use
your apps anyway so if I you have to
brainwash us yeah I just like it so much
it's so frustrating being brainwashed it
well we'll get to that I'm sure that's a
good sequitur into southern childhood
sequitur into southern charm but my fit
stories yes better sequitur into all
about Bravo oh what I'm calling the next
45 minutes of the show Charlie Sheen
says he can no longer for child support
claims he was blacklisted in Hollywood
reports people Charlie Sheen is having a
rough time paying child support for four
of his children
the former anger management star 52
filed requests to modify his child
support payments to Denise Richards and
Brooke Mueller in court documents
obtained by people Sheen who shares two
daughters with Richards and twin sons
with Mueller claims he can't afford to
make his monthly payments because quote
he's been unable to find steady work and
has been blacklisted from many aspects
of the entertainment industry the actor
claims he's had a significant reduction
in his earnings and is in dire financial
crisis when with less than ten million
dollars to his name the document also
lists several deaths she has been unable
to pay because of his finances including
both a pool service and a gardening
service which are both noted as past due
but like ten million dollars should
cover pool and gardening services I
would hope a war child like I would hope
like how much child support for four
kids I mean I would think it wouldn't be
ten million dollars no but like I think
he's four I was reading some of the uh
you know the gossip yeah and I think he
had like a 200 million dollar fortune
which in the past few years he's blown
to ten million dollars literally been
literally been and you know he was
paying child support as someone who was
making 200 million and right and now
it's entered two baby mamas and this
sort of fuels the rumors that Denise
Richards could be joining the cast of
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills yes
because someone might need to be making
that Bravo money what would you think
about it was any stretchers join the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills um I'm
here for it because I think that I like
her I don't know her that well and she's
so pretty but in general I'm not here
for traditional like for established
celebrities joining housewives so like
when Rinna and Eileen Davidson did like
it took me a really like a few seasons
to get
to them not gonna lie and it wasn't
until like oh I means last season that I
liked her and then she left us which was
so hard but I'm so glad that she came
full circle
is it is it just me or do I feel like
Lisa Rinna's a little bit more of a
household name and Eileen David she is
but uh I just felt like that like Eileen
but the negative is ro that means
something that Lisa Rinna it seemed like
she was using housewives to like further
her career which I get in certain
situations but I don't know it just
didn't seem like I wouldn't have cast
her but now I'm so happy we have her did
you feel that way about Kyle and Kim
Richards no okay because they were early
child starts in had been years yeah and
they really like Kyle Richards is really
Beverly Hills like she's friends with
Kris Jenner right she spends with
everyone and she is a staple now it's to
Richard's that we have now it's kind of
Kim Kyle and Denise it's a lot I didn't
realize she's a Richards they're not
related no I don't think so unless that
would be like that would be I should
like to get them on how supports us and
they find out they're related yeah by
like some forth distant cousin that
would be great
I think Deniz is really good friends
with Lisa which would make sense and
like Harry Hamlin they're all actors
they're all in that world so I would
kind of think it would be like a good I
don't know it's nice to see Hollywood
come into like the reap like the reality
television world I agree with that it
says so much about the reality
television world yes you can't really
have the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills without having Hollywood because
you have to write so I can I can allow
it
yeah okay we're allowing this we're
going this and I'm sure there will be
like a lot of interesting T around
Denise and Charlie and all the drums of
course so I'm here for it okay you're
gonna watch and I am always gonna you're
not gonna not watch um and so like can
you confirm or deny the rumors cuz
they're filming now I can confirm that
how do I want to say this I think you're
gonna be very happy with this new season
and the cast members on it I I could see
Denise being a part of it if that helped
see you I hear you okay yeah you hear me
um and as far as everyone else to read
is back correct yes Teddy's back yes and
then the others of course your guys back
yeah that I don't know
I will literally I need like I need thus
teens to like really do their research
and figure this out for me okay I need
them to coasters you know what we have
to do we honor a possibility because now
it's it'll be solved in a minute we'll
have any crime solved by dinnertime
oh no wait don't be lunch what are you
talking about by 12 o'clock the toasters
right let me know what my executives are
doing I know that I love Erica so much
but I would also I think I would
understand the decision I love her but
it is a little bit like the whole
ice-cold thing it is hard to get to know
her and you really do need that moment
in reality TV to like open up to
somebody and like get that inner I mean
the yeah like she's gotten better over
the years but she is so pretty like
ice-cold yes but I kind of under I
understand her like not letting everyone
in all at once but I wish right
she just needs like understand that she
like has to right
she's Erika Jayne right but you're still
on Real Housewives and it's revolves
around the relationships of women right
and you have to have a relationship with
them but like the way that like her I
lead him he said like they are squad
goals even her relationship with Kyle
like when they went to Greece together
like that was so fun and so cute but
yeah it's hard for her to get to that
point but the relationship between her
and her II was like the friendship I
never knew that I needed I know and I
really I want to be friends with Erica G
I even want to be friends with der rebe
sometimes I'm like I'm there for it did
I tell you that we loved right now yeah
we what changed though so season one
could not stand yes season two what
changed I'm I'm really not sure but like
I just found her to be like not I
understood her side more yes she does
she opens her mouth and but she was oh
this is what I was I think she was
really like the only one this season who
was like really keeping it very
interesting right and the only one who
was willing to put her foot in her mouth
because Lisa Rinna has taken a back seat
and I totally got and I also love I love
up what's the word hmm
the word anyway I love a peaceful Lisa
Rinna oh you oh you like a
non-conference not stirring the pot Lisa
right you where she's like right because
I can see she's like so happy yeah she
really is very successful and her
husband is very successful so she
doesn't need to be like clawing to make
drama happy she's a household name she
so I think she's earned the right to sit
back a little bit spare and I heard her
say on a radio or something that like
kyle-and-lisa I get paid the moat Lisa
Vanderpump they get paid the most and
they don't ever get into it and look
into the drama really our buddy scrappy
and so she's not going to either why
should she be like you know dragging
herself through the mud
why should she debase yourself if the
others aren't either she's right and
they're getting paid more right exactly
they're on the same playing field do you
want Josie yes have you been liking it I
have been I actually I think that to
recap Oh see this week so that's perfect
okay um I've been liking it and that's
been my new thing this is my first
season I've watched like wholeheartedly
I'm like eight episodes in wow I never
really paid attention to OC before the
season and waiter you're caught up right
I'm caught okay I'm so like watching
like Tamra break her foot like I was
sitting there just laughing my ass off
no same and I have a few different
thoughts about OC first of all I really
feel the like the women know that last
season was so bad in there like they're
Taylor trying they're trying taking 15
shots they're like let's get [ __ ] up
and see what happens we don't care I was
kind of bummed that camera when she hurt
her foot it was like hilarious yeah but
now it's gonna be like annoying and a
big deal and like she's almost like she
needs like surgery or something like
that's annoying because was just a one
night out thing like right exactly I'm
secuence it's like weren't wards the
crime and now we have to like watch her
go through and Eddie's going through
that heart thing so I'm right oh my god
this is [ __ ] but I like the Chanin in
Tamara like back with Vicki they're all
like friends again oh you don't like
Shannon you don't like Vicki I don't
like Vicki I love Shannon I love which
is crazy because for a long time when
everyone like Ellis liked her when she
was friends with Vicki well I've never
really been so big on Vicki but I've
understood why she's around right um
she's like the matriarch of Bravo that's
right and he would take a lot for her to
go like she like even if she has a bad
season and if she had the season another
housewife did like they would go but
she's a staple and I get it right um but
so when Shannon and Vicki were friends
like I was never really not here for
Shannon I don't know what changed with
me with her her friendship with Tamra
and like I think she's just so funny
like when she goes to another country
and starts saying words it's hilarious
to me even on the ropes course when
Vicki would like when Shannon was
and she's like and they're like it's a
ropes course like I did that ropes
course when I was seven years old and
now women are like fifty and freaking
out I was peeing my pants laughing I
just thought this was like the funny
like they're not trying to be the
richest people and yeah which I love
right well that's another thing it's
like the Real Housewives mostly is like
very aspirational and bright but with OC
it's very real
what do you think of Emily and Jeana I'm
open to them okay just because I'm so so
happy Peggy and Lydia aren't they're
like I don't know which one I like to
wear less honestly because you would
think would be Peggy because she was
like such a troublemaker but Lydia like
really really bothered me I felt like
she was so mean to Shannon she wanted
Vicki and Tamra to get back together and
then she wanted Shannon like to have no
one like she when she was being the
friendship was for like why are you
friendship whispering Shannon and
Vicki's relationship right exactly was
trying to leave Shannon out and Chatham
was already feeling so low about her she
needed it the most I think like she
needed that friendship the most and she
was just kicking in the car maybe it was
like trying to take away her friend
right and it really bugged me last
season what like Cheyenne went through
it was so hard to watch but I felt like
just so good knowing that like so many
people I'm sure related to her struggle
like so many people struggle with their
weight and to do it like on TV while
your husband's leaving you and things
aren't good and like blah blah blah it
was I think it really helped a lot of
people you know 100 I think actually
Shannon's story like despite any funny
storyline was a real thing that does
happen in like she's going through this
act of divorce you know ever you see
every inch of Shannon beador last season
and the season and there's something
nice that you can like relate to like
she's kind of like the everyday
housewife she really is you know and she
also has that level of like aspiration
on this that house that they used to
live in they should have never moved out
a hundred I mean got my gosh should I
don't know why they moved out like you
just you never know what's really going
on you never made it seem like it was a
money thing but assuming it wasn't they
should have never moved out and you're a
Kelly Dodd fan I am which is so like
I've been a fan of her since saw season
last season she was amazing she was like
the Sonia glass season like above the
fray not really fighting being hilarious
and crazy and everything that we needed
and this season I love her and I max
really glad that there's a risk now
between Vicki and Kelly because Vicki
clung on to Kelly when she had no one
she like kind of used her but then it
turned into a real friendship right well
and now she has her friends back and
this is how you treat her and Kelly is
the only one like who would ever go so
Belote like she knows she definitely
knows things about Vicki that we need to
know oh so if anyone's ever gonna tell
them to us it's gonna be Kelly and I'm
so here for it I just I'm here for Kelly
Tamra Shannon Wow okay that's I mean I'm
I would agree with that I would go there
are the most polarizing characters Kelly
told me that she gets like 500 DMS from
guys a day that's all so I love her
attitude and I understand why when she
was like when it was the first episode
yes I was explaining her new situation
she was like we moved out of me sold the
house I moved into this apartment Julie
they're showing it like it's obviously
smaller than her old house with all of
her big old furniture so it looks a
little silly yeah she's like and I love
it I'm like any juxtaposition from
Shannon who's like we we've we've moved
on chef David has a new girlfriend which
is all very sad her trying to get the
ring off and Taryn was like like
breaking her fingers my god
I'm like oh my god this is ridiculous
that was Julie is like a little like she
is like a 30 year old woman trapped in a
14 year old girl's body she's so
precocious she's just hearing all of her
mom's like sexual antics I'm like oh she
needs to date who sassy little brother
because they're the two smartest people
on Bravo there are there are like the
voices of reason and they're not even
old enough to drink and I I would agree
with that that's a great pull no let's
get Hattie singer to set them up I'm in
this all comes back to Bravo so it I'm
so in my Zoe okay so and but what was
also funny is like they're in Mexico
like obviously being crazy right and
then they flashback to Gina and her kids
like oh so someone needs to tell Gina
that if she likes I can't no she can't
leave the candle sitting on the bed like
that is not okay what do you think of
her accent um as someone who's from Long
Island right I think it's funny and I'm
here for it I just hope she doesn't like
rely on her Long Island miss too much
because that's not a thing and it's in
her tagline so it's like okay we get it
but she's always like the novelty act
like say kulfi kulfi
like that's a one and done thing yeah
move on from right now we're now we're
moving past right so what do you think
the fact that she's never seen her
Bin's apartment there's something weird
there and we said this like there are a
few instances where like women go on the
show to get a divorce or their husbands
put them on the show to you know give
them something to do while they're
getting divorced
yeah and this is giving me those sort of
vibes got it okay that's fair that's
fair and the other one who I can't
remember her name ever but she looks
like chessy from The Parent Trap so he
just called her chesty here um she does
look like Jessie from The Parent Trap
she's another one her husband like her
poster chat like yeah that's weird to me
but what the problem is right now is
like Vicki Tamra Shannon now even Kelly
have a history the heroes through it
like they are almost like a
dysfunctional family and it's really
hard to bring in new people to get into
that groove because there's so much here
and there I don't see them you know when
I was interviewing Tamra Vicki and
Shannon about the new girls on my weekly
pregame on bravotv.com
comes out every Sunday I asked each one
of them I was like what do you think
just a generic what do you think of the
new girls and Tamra was like well
Shannon's never gonna give them a chance
and Vicki was like Shannon's never gonna
give him a chance and Shannon was like
they're nice I was like this is so good
like that's like nice like that's like
the least no one wants to be called nice
right that is the most boring adjective
you could call someone and I was like
Shannon can you elaborate she's like
nope can't elaborate they're nice I was
like oh well Kelly I'm watching having
five said that she likes them so I could
see Kyle he's the newest housewife I
could see her like being the most open
to them and now that she doesn't have
Vicki and like they she sounds good not
being the only new one any right like
she's she's a vet now I'll um I'm open
to seeing how this season goes and how
these new girls can integrate into the
group but if it doesn't work out may I
suggest bringing back some of the oh
jeez and I would like to nominate Alexis
Bellino okay
everyone loves Alexis I know I loved her
even when she was on the show it's like
yes she's crazy but like she's like a
character and it's it's good television
it's great television maybe she you
don't want to be her best friend's shirt
or like you can't relate to why she's
doing the things that she does but like
but I want to talk about her I know like
years later we're still talking about
Alexis Bellino and it's like if it ever
gets really really bad you could bring
back Gretchen but that would just keep
her way too much pleasure
I mean if we in the fact that she's
still not married even though she
proposed to Slade but she's still the
weirdest thing I've ever seen
on TV because it was like an act of
desperation to stay on the show and not
invite her cast mates poorly thought out
Christ yes it's a Slade like really and
they're still not married so like she's
clearly waiting to get back on TV to get
married that that would that would seem
to be the correct response yeah that
would be something so like I would
understand if you have her brought back
Gretchen it would just give her away too
much joy yeah that's like too much like
we don't want to like we don't want to
do that and Heather Dubrow there was
always a spot for Heather Dubrow in my
book a lot of people were upset when
Heather Dubrow got off the show like I
didn't I never thought that Heather was
like the main person like she was always
kind of like right in the middle like
she was involved she wasn't boring but
she wasn't the most appealing but a lot
of backlash happened because Heather
Dubrow was off the show no and I
understand that cuz also she wasn't she
didn't get into the thick of it which
was nice but she did have real
friendships with my camera and Shannon
and that's what's it like that's what
makes the show really good that's why
New York this season and we must start
talking about it we must and can I just
say outside 30 rock the other day people
protested the fact that Kenya Moore is
no longer on the Real Housewives Atlanta
protested outside 30 rock holding up
posters and you would already asked me
to be on the show and I just remember
thinking I was like it all relates back
to Bravo like Bravo was a [ __ ]
phenomenon that people will protest not
even in own City to get a housewife back
on the show
that's a protest I can get behind I
should start protesting for housewives I
want back due to 30 rock Brandi
Glanville
speaking of housewives that are coming
back yes Jill Zarin do you want her to
come back if there was ever a time for
her to come back it would be now because
he's gone Bobby's gone better unless our
good mom and I I'm here for it I'd be
curious to see like what she does when
she's back because I feel like she's
definitely been humbled by not being
asked back for so long well that's
that's another thing like would she be
as drama fueled because now it's true
even like that short scene that we saw
out coming out of the funeral between
her and Bethenny this it was like a real
moment yes in drama field it was like
I'm alone in bed Lee was like I'm alone
too and there was something just so it
felt good to just be five minutes like I
don't know if Jill Zarin could carry the
whole season that I
no either and but it you can't bring
someone into New York now who's just
totally random and new except Tinsley
did a pretty good job getting into it
but like Jules mine's seen I know
Dorinda said last night that Jules
deserves another chance don't you ever
put her back that's her although I did
like mine you look my favorite she might
have been one of the worst housewives of
all time well the only thing that she
really contributed was like the Asian
Jewishness because that was on
everything we had to do with like being
Asian and being Jewish she like was one
of those people who gave like Jutes
like Mamie embarrass yeah she was
talking about her Judaism it's like she
was don't act like that Jews don't talk
about being Jewish all jewish all the
time right it just happens to be
something that Jewish people are not
like the first thing they unless she's
an Orthodox Jew and it you know she's
preparing kosher meals and waiting to
separate between eating milk and meat I
can understand why her whole life might
be wrapped around Judaism but if you're
just a Jew reformed right like yeah we
live in New York City like everyone
everyone is a reform Jew here right this
that we live in New York City okay
that's interesting yeah I won't probably
bring back jewels cuz she wasn't that
great tell me about Tinsley because
right before the show you were like used
to like her now I don't know
and we didn't dive in we did not dive in
uh so this will bring us to cartoon yeah
I mean like really used to like Tinsley
I thought she was like such a fresh
young vibe and she is like back in the
day she was the real housewife of New
York so like right it was the it girl
it all comes full circle for her to like
get arrested and then come on to
actually go on Real Housewives like is a
big deal right so last season I thought
she was cute and fresh in like her in
Scott I thought they were so cute and
now this season it's just a Scott's cute
I do okay yeah he seems like a nice guy
he's never seen a bad side of him he is
honestly like I've met him in person in
Chicago and in New York many times he's
genuinely a really nice guy I think he's
really cute and I really like them
together but all the breaking up and
getting back together seems weird to me
and a little thirsty to be talked about
and then she like goes on vacation now
and is and she's like taking a picture
in front of like the Leaning Tower of
Pisa alone she's like taken by Scott
like so that we know that they're
together writing her bringing a glam
squad to carta hennya in a non
air-conditioned home so like you're
gonna sweat up all your makeup anyway
you're wearing a smoky eye to breakfast
and you're just having them braid your
hair like right you do that yourself I
mean I actually can't braid my own hair
but I wouldn't brings - I wouldn't hire
glam squad to do it for me I would I
would asked one of the bringing them
across like international borders into
this today just to get great just to
wake up with all the other girls who
just had like massive diarrhea and are
in sweatpants and Tinsley comes
downstairs like right I'm like I love
some of the clothes that she wears but
like she changed three separate times
yesterday on the island yeah she came in
with like her lace bridal bathing suit
cover-up which was really cute I thought
I know Isaac Mizrahi did not like it but
I was here for it and I did right there
was someone else wearing it he would
have liked it like it was Bethany just
you know sometimes it's about who wears
it rather than what you're wearing agree
sometimes um and then then she wore like
that blue dress that she spelled spilled
red wine over like why are you drinking
red wine in like over 100 degree heat
it's like the worst time to drink red
wine right yes only in winter and then
she wore the cutest bathing suit I've
ever seen like it was like he savart oh
my god I loved it I wish she just worth
of what like I wish she wore that the
whole time it's like she's just trying
too hard and that takes the coolness out
of it right you wouldn't you would
prefer her just to like that's just who
she is she owns it she doesn't make a
big deal out of it she's just like yeah
changed 50 times if I want to or she's
like in the water oh my hair wet like
I'm someone who doesn't get my hair wet
but like when I do I'm not like oh my
god really and it's like this is your
trip that you plan like what you weren't
gonna go in the water yeah on an island
well that's I think that's the funniest
thing that she planned the entire trip
she's like I've been going here for
years and like even during the boat trip
when literally Carole's vomiting
Bethany's holding her hair back
everyone's crying like Ramona can't swim
Tinsley's like what this is fine thanks
she's five she can't admit that she
[ __ ] up
well that is react and that the trip is
treacherous and it was like yes the boat
was horrible but there were a lot of
other elements to the trip that were
very treacherous like everyone getting
sick the house didn't seem like it
looked beautiful but it didn't seem very
comfortable yes and that's all on her
and she won't like take it she's just
like no you guys just don't understand
it like I do and she thinks the trip
sucks because of all the fighting which
it does but like if they were in you
know one like the fish tank room in
Dubai like I think everyone would be
feeling a little better
of course even in tequila Mexico like
right it would have it would have felt
better I mean yeah tequila made it great
because they're all like hugging so
drunk in the pool
Ramona's dying but like it wasn't just
the fighting and the fighting hadn't
made it anyway right the fighting made
it like a trip for the books which now
she can take credit first she should be
grateful for the fighting or else no one
would be talking about her trip what did
you think about Bethenny like holding
Carole's hair back when she's vomiting
because that is something that like only
a good good friend would do not your
sworn enemy this entire season
totally and that makes sense me that
reminds me like sometimes you have a
like a falling out with a friend and
it's like you're no longer friends but
there are things that might happen in
life like a death or something where
it's like this is bigger than us Jill
Zarin Bethenny exactly right we might
die on a boat you're throwing up I got
you right like this could be the last
time we see each other I'm gonna hold
your [ __ ] hair back
totally and that's just see that's like
the human thing to do and if Bethenny
like wasn't helpful or I mean I guess we
wouldn't even know she didn't hold her
hair about cuz we've been like why
wasn't her hair was pulled back so she
didn't really need someone yeah so we
wouldn't even be talking about it but it
just was like a really nice gesture in
what you thought might be a dying moment
yeah I actually thought it was really
sweet like I actually felt like this was
the olive branch under extenuating
circumstances that that was gonna bring
them back together and they just kind of
be like you know what [ __ ] all the
history we've had what's weird about
them is I still don't really know why
they don't like each other and we talked
about this last time when I thought I
was team Carole and you said routine
Bethenny but there really wasn't this
one instance of like Carole betrayed
Bethenny your balcony portrayed Carole
like it was just over this course of
time when we weren't filming that all of
a sudden they're not friends well
Claudia and I have a theory that we
really got into last week um about one
of the reasons why this might have
happened and it's like Bethenny was
really like the main person in the
friendship and Carole was sort of her
sidekick right which was fine and it
worked for them for a long time gonna
bump herself up to main person and it's
like that just changed the dynamics of
their friendship because no one told
Bethenny that and nothing happened that
would bump Carole up she just decided
like between Bethenny and Jill we were
saying like Jill was the main person
Bethenny was the sidekick and then
Bethenny's stock really rose yeah and
then it got competitive and Jill didn't
want that sort of friendship with
Bethenny so therefore at the friendship
ended the Carole just decided her stock
was up and no betting right without at
one Kyle got her own sidekick with
Tinsley and she's like I don't need to
be someone else's sidekick and to like
how like just decided she didn't want to
be a sidekick anymore I was just
actually being up right right and so
Bethenny
see the stock rise and Carol didn't tell
her that she was rising it right she was
inflating so it changed the power
dynamics of the friendship risk and then
so Carol is not gonna like do sidekick
things like text her all the time really
and then Bethany is like why don't you
answer my texts like things have changed
and Bethany literally has no clue why
but it's just a mentality change of
Carol's that she can't say like you
can't say I'm a psychic and I don't want
to be one anymore
they definitely go at it at the Reunion
I'm okay we need to talk about the
reunion because I thought - after the
boat episode they were on good terms on
the island and after the boat episode
that's the sort of thing that brings
people together maybe we can move
forward they're never gonna be best
friends again it's like an ex-boyfriend
like they've seen you naked they know
everything about you you're not just
gonna you can't erase that right right
right but they could be acquaintances
and co-workers for sure totally and I
could be cordial what happened at the
Reunion because Carol is no longer a
housewife Carol is no longer housewife
LuAnn wasn't there you know she went to
she went to go get help you know so she
couldn't we address the LuAnn thing
Bethany is sort of her advocate when
they're there because Bethany had been
hanging out with LuAnn like the weekend
before and had seen it all kind of go
down so Bethany was really sort of
speaking on behalf of LuAnn so they're
real friends now they're real friends
you know I think the interesting thing
about the season is like Sonja and
Bethenny cause Sonja was kind of Bethany
a sidekick this whole time even though
Sonja has her own presence
no she was a sidekick like friendship I
never liked that friendship is
everything to me and I said like sonja
has been an amazing friend to Bethany
this season like yeah through and
through and if Bethany ever there's a
mean word about Sonja again or like
turns on her I will not forgive her like
wow so like if it's go if it steams on
your team Bethany your team Sonja it
depends on what it's about but like when
Bethenny was like so like Bethany has
been really need to Sony a few times in
the past like yeah it and it was kind of
unnecessary and just like too aggressive
and if that happens again
I will really be upset with Bethenny
because Sonja really got her through
this trip and like through this season I
feel like I agree I mean I think ever
that ever since it's like tipsy girl
fight that went down I think it was like
last season her shoe seasons ago there
was always a little bit of like they
knew who each other was like she'd be
like okay Sonja's kind of crazy and
certain you'd be like Bethenny's a [ __ ]
but then this
it just felt like they they only had
each other right and LuAnn kind of
played both sides because the before
that Dorinda fight LuAnn was kind of
friends with everybody like it really
everyone missed her when she was away
everyone that supported her like seems
like LuAnn and Dorinda were like best
friend they were super like when LuAnn
got divorced like she told it like she
sat with Dorinda and films like when
after the rehab like she calls to Rinda
like of course and so for Dorinda to
turn on her like that was wild oh and
you'll see I don't think you saw it yet
like Dorinda helps her with her cabaret
show and gets her all these Shivani
dresses like it's nice how the dresses
yeah okay so you see her like Riley she
was a great friend to LuAnn yes and I
think the problem was friends can have
drunken fights and like that's fine I
think first of all that LuAnn was sober
and remembers truly everything during
that doesn't remember that in like the
the scale of what she said and like
Dorinda said things that like she can't
take back right and to LuAnn it felt
like things that she was thinking but
never said but because she's drunk she
said then yes whereas LuAnn all she said
all she was accused of was maybe being
judgmental which you can which is
subjective I was someone's attacking you
about like a mug shot like you're gonna
be defensive right I mean I don't think
during that actually thinks those things
I just think when you're drunk it's
really easy to insult someone who's
going through a really sensitive time I
don't think that she wishes any ill-will
on LuAnn I don't know I don't thinks
like at all I think the rindo really
needs like just wants to be liked and
loved and thought of as like the
sweetest person ever well then she can't
like drink like she does I agree I agree
it's just unfortunate some people drink
and they just go to the dark side and
then other people drink in their Sonia
and they're the life of the stairs the
drink apps absolutely what's interesting
it was like the Sonja Ramona dynamic
this year which we didn't see a lot of
right like Ramona was really on like
with Dorinda more even with Carole more
Tinsley like she was screaming at
Bethenny even though Bethenny Sonja and
Ramona all sit on the same side of the
couch
Bethenny Sonja and Ramona well that the
sides of the couch were all [ __ ] up
because Luann's not there yes and I
think Ramona had Ramona got into like a
car accident and so part of her face was
like was scratched or something so she
switched sides to in order to like have
a better side okay so the couch I'm I'm
not gonna take with like so much weight
yeah don't take it with so much because
let me saw it really didn't make sense
and Carol is sitting next to Andy
Bethany and Carol flank
Andy so Andy was just like that's the
most important part he just volleyballs
yes so like what happens at the Reunion
a lot goes down there's a lot of
different I think
everyone sort of goes after Bethany in
their own sort of way the the
interesting and with the Bethany and
Carol thing is like whens but when
Bethany is talking or explaining
something Carol always has like there's
always like two camera angles going on
at this reunion where it's like you know
how you show like what the housewives
are reacting to the myth this is like
the house is reacting to the housewife
correct and so this is that and it's
like three split-screen sort of so you
see like two reactions of a clip or you
see their reaction it's just crazy and
Bethany and Carol II can't help
themselves and they're just getting
pettier and pettier and like lashing out
lashing out lashing out there's really
no resolution there and I just don't
think that Carol I think Kara was just
over it
I think she's just like I couldn't take
it anymore you know I mean she ran the
marathon which was great but her
storyline really wasn't the end-all
be-all this year I mean she'd really
didn't have the mean outside of her
fighting with Bethany she really had the
main storyline it and well like what's
going on her in her life and like her
one Cosmo column that she needs like
months to write it does not a show make
okay so you're not team Carol still yeah
team Carol still oh yes anything I've
just been like getting further and
further away from team Carol Bethany's
just like broke my heart in car dannion
it's like she does have so much going on
in her life and she seems to be the only
one who's understanding like the
severity of her fight with Carol like
that's she treated Carol like a best
best friend probably told her everything
and like knowing Carol doesn't like her
anymore has all of this information
about her she already feels so
vulnerable just in life totally that I
like she I felt everything she was
feeling and being like in a foreign
country and it's not super comfortable
and you're fighting with everyone and
it's a treacherous I know you're patient
so I want you to see it but I will say
that Dorinda comes after Bethany in a
way that Bethany can't get out of like
you know how she can always like argue
herself out of like a situation or
really explain her side or this and that
Dorinda kind of comes at Bethany in a
way that's like oh you think you support
women well if this sort of happened and
Bethany has to confront the fact that
she was kind of a hypocrite and it was
really nice to see and it made me more
team bethany than ever before oh because
she because she admitted she because she
had she literally was she couldn't argue
or intellectualize her way out of it
like Dorinda had called her out on
something and Bethany was like you're
right and and that made me like her a
lot more because you want to see them at
least own up to their [ __ ] you don't
want to see her denial denial deny
there's nothing wrong there's nothing
worse than someone who can't admit when
they're wrong
agreed especially when literally
everyone is telling you that this is how
it was when they when they roll back the
cameras and you see that you said this
one thing like right on your [ __ ] oh
that's the most I think that's the most
nine part about being a housewife it's
like when you say just one thing like
it's so blown up and can't even remember
like it was like one work thing out of a
sentence a paragraph that's just the
worst I'm glad I'm so excited for the
ringing in so Bethany tweeted last night
yeah about you know vaguely about
Carol's decision to leave housewives
because Carol made it seem like it was
her decision and Bethany said basically
no one has ever left without Bravo
firing them yep uh what's the T I think
it was a mutual decision honestly I
don't think I think Carol was just kind
of ready to move on personally I think
that she just I don't want to see like
she gave up as a housewife but you have
to give something in order to be on a
reality show you have to be able to be
willing to show every single aspect of
your life like when Ramona wouldn't talk
about Mario and he was like why did you
sign up for the show if you weren't
gonna [ __ ] talk about your goddamn
divorce like you have to be able to talk
about that stuff and Carole was really
shutting herself it more inward inward
inward and I think it was just a mutual
decision but her statement did you read
her statement and at the end of it when
she was like next I was like wow this is
the best way to like sign off of a Real
Housewives like this is so funny
and I think Bethenny won the battle
let's put it that way sure sure I think
Bethenny what maybe she won the war
maybe she won the war oh wait I think
she won the war like idea all season
like cour was winning the battles and
that's why people we're like team Carole
and watch what happens live and stuff
but Bethenny is winning the war it was
as we said to you before it was nice to
see someone combat Bethenny with equal
intellect like it no but the way the
Carole are you
it was so frustrating listening to him
are you because it's like they'll
Bethenny will say something about how
she feels
yeah and Carol will just take one nugget
of that and like I'd say about that a
not true right when it's like first of
all we don't even know whether or not
that's true and you're ignoring the
larger point here I agree and they
weren't really like they were sort of
just talking at each other not with each
other at all they were arguing about
like timelines of text and you're like
who the [ __ ] cares about a timeline of
tax like I'm telling you you didn't
respond to this also Bravo give us the
screenshots like I knew that you have
that oh right like just we slide over
you can see that they like Meghan King
Edmonds and Kelly Dodd like your husband
right we see the receipts like show us
the receipts Bravo show us a seed I
think it was just a mutual decision and
I think Bethany really I don't want to
say bullied but I think that Bethany
like showed her cards and I don't think
Carol could handle it necessarily I'd so
interesting i thought carol was talking
about that honestly I did two halves
actually kind of surprised that she was
leaving I thought she had one more
season in her yeah I thought one more
you never leave that the height of the
fight right because then you either Dex
has settled and you've either you
increase it or you can resolve it in
some really big way next season and then
and this is just done like this was the
final straw like I don't see them being
friends I see them being cordial but I
don't see them being friends ever again
me neither too much has happened yeah
heard a rumor that Carol actually came
for Andy at the Reunion um she had her
moments with Andy for sure in fact he
had his moments with all of them pretty
much except Sonja and Tinsley so like he
was fun I don't want to say fighting but
he was like arguing with every single
one of them outside of Sounion Tinsley
Wow yeah so they were separate like
people always come out Andy whether it's
seating arrangements or how they're
edited or this and that like Andy's the
face of it so whether or not Andy has a
whether or not Andy was in the cutting
room right he's not like editing it
himself but they're always gonna attack
him and I think that he does a really
good job you know you always call him
like the Housewives whisperer and he is
that like he's able just be like okay
this isn't a good look for you yes
settle down
yeah so we need to talk about the boat
because so many people were like they
have no footage it's gonna be
anti-climactic and I really did not
think that it was I thought we saw we
got the gist Sony I Latins Lea before it
even got really bad being like we're on
a plane with one propeller like I felt
that in my soul like that would have
been me I'm the most like
especially of boats the fact that they
didn't have life jackets was so
unacceptable and Ramona can't swim like
legs but Mona can't that's what she's
screaming like she's by herself
screaming I can't see what I mean and
the fact that if the anchor hadn't been
cut cut they would have kept us capsized
yeah it was genuinely scary like it
wasn't like this was a doctored footage
of like the guy going like this I mean
we couldn't film half of it because it
was genuinely unsafe to do that and so
even though a lot of people thought that
we weren't gonna get a lot of footage
you the audience saw as much footage as
we could safely show right and I felt
good about the amount of footage that
that was shown and especially knowing
know how that they're all fine in the
how it ends like I got the point
I saw enough seasickness but I would
have been throwing up hardcore like how
and potentially saying that's every
afternoon in Cartagena yeah is that part
true yeah Wow that is true she
definitely I mean I've never been to
carta Hannya so I don't know I wasn't on
a boat but the fact that Tinsley was
just in so denial about how terrible it
was like of all the Housewives trips
ever this was by far probably the worst
one we've ever seen in terms of just
like safety and diarrhea and like gross
Ness I just liked that they kept
flashing back to the Paia that they all
ate and like Bethany and NZ really oh
I'm not and they're the only ones who
didn't end up with like full-blown
diarrhea like Bethany woke up like
completely refreshed the next day I
can't believe luan shat the bed oh they
are like there's like sick to that point
that you can't make it to the bathroom I
mean at least when I I've never been
that month not that I can remember
not in my adult life were like like
that's crazy oh yeah I still like own
her poop smearer she's like that's not
mine I know what mine look like I'm like
how do you know what your poop smearer
looks like so yes poop get poop smear on
the fire right you're not like 2 years
old
those are like grown women also Tinsley
really owes the group an apology and I
would be mad at her not even it's not
her fault that like the ship sank but
like the fact that she can't take
accountability and be like wow I'm
really sorry I put you guys in that
position
totally I got it and night was scary and
when we were talking about when Sonia
was like you don't get it since Lee I
have a daughter and tinsy was like so
why I have a dog we were like that's not
this scene and we were talking about it
dogs are children animals are children
in a way you know
at the same right and like I am a dog
aunt and I I love Co like more than I
can explain and if I were on a sinking
ship like I don't know that I would like
be like hey I don't know if I would feel
as like scared of someone who has like
children back home if you we would have
to have a conversation if something ever
happened to someone their dog could go
live with someone else and they wouldn't
even know the difference like correct if
I having fed their whole life is like
[ __ ] up and I'm frightened
rights like a little different it's a
little different yes so that was crazy
and that was another thing about tensley
also there was a weird moment at lunch
on the island when Tinsley and Carole
are talking about fashion and Bethenny
is like dying inside and I didn't agree
with Bethenny like you don't have to say
everything that you're thinking all the
time like toasters Bethenny does yes
right but the conversation was painful
in the way that Tim seemed was talking
to cow she's like yeah State LeBron like
I can it's amazing like that's not how
you talk to like your best friend like
that's how you talk to someone that you
don't really know you like talk about
clothes and you're like this season
saying that round was just everything
right it best friend you'd be like oh my
god this was like a really cool line and
like I loved it like you just talk about
fake conversation yeah me and then
Karl's like oh it's Lee Brad's well
Aboriginal it's like that's so cool but
I think that's what Bethenny was like
picking up on know she was ready to just
pounce and attack and like was gonna
call anyone out for being fake and
Bethenny might have not had diarrhea but
she had diarrhea of the mouth on this
trip like when she was talking about the
tables yeah
oh my she constantly has diarrhea she
can't let it go for someone who
sometimes like doesn't open up yeah she
has word vomit like emotional word vomit
and absolutely it's like cuz I
understand now why she doesn't start
sometimes because she can't stop she
physically has like restrain herself or
like not pay attention in order to in
order to like make sure she can get out
of this safely right yes so people are
asking what level of planning does Bravo
have in these trips like what tinsley
plan the trip yeah how what does that
actually mean
I mean I think that she's been there
before it's a house that she knows she
knows the people Bravo does take a lot
of care into planning the trips we have
the cast safety on the line it's
expensive they're staying in glorious
places I mean it's week-long like Bravo
has extensive extensive help and
preparation into doing these trips right
the boat thing happened to be the
you know really awful thing that
happened and I honestly think it was a
fluke it wasn't like Bravo set them up
to be in this really bad position like
this happened to be a really traumatic
situation that no one no one would have
wanted like we wanted them to be like on
a catamaran like sunbathing and drinking
martinis like we're going so well like
this wasn't planned by Bravo in order to
get them into a shitty situation I
didn't feel like it was yes some people
did they would just be like oh great
Bravo's but it wasn't act like it felt
very very real to me it was and we
couldn't even film it and like we
learned a lot of lessons until you know
certain safety precautions and what we
need to go through but it wasn't wasn't
we had prepared as best as we thought
just happened to be a fluke so two
questions one did the way never get her
phone back that she left on the island
the producer said they would go back for
it I doubt that happen I don't know if
she got it back I doubt she got it back
I get right cuz I'm like who would go
back there and an hour and a half when
they were doing they were doing the
clock and like they left at 3:15 and
it's like their show means four o'clock
on the boat I'm like oh my god they have
45 more minutes like I know like feeling
like screaming at each other
scream mazing so the boat was obviously
a traumatic experience yes it affects
how things play out throughout the seat
throughout the rest of the season or
like it's happened it's done we're
moving forward it's pretty much it's
happened it's done we're moving forward
they definitely talked about it you know
you see kind of the aftermath after they
all kind of have diarrhea like got food
poisoning and they're like laughing
about it and it brings some of them
closer together and they talk about it
in the reunion for sure but in terms of
the rest of the season until the reunion
it is just like that's what happened and
then we move forward there's more drama
that unfolds got it yes okay so a few
more Bravo related questions for you we
talked about LuAnn being in rehab a
little bit yeah there was also news that
she was using her children's inheritance
to fund her life yes because I think
Victoria came out saying that yeah kids
are like suing her yes because they're
she's blowing through like the entire
inheritance of like the lifestyle that
she was living I'm not sure about that
other than that's what happened I don't
know about Luann's like spending account
but like it seemed like she spends that
much some things require a lot of money
ooh
some things require a lot of money can
we also talk about that the women of New
York housewives have the most insane
bodies I've ever seen I mean like
watching them all in bathing suits was
like they
like they're kind of alive I can't even
decide who has the best or there's no
way no there who like they just look so
good and healthy and fit like especially
LuAnn like no they're like they're like
stoned and they look they're hot yeah
they're hot they're really hot and I
would say Tamra's probably like the
hottest terms of body as a housewife oh
I mean her lying naked on the floor as a
lesbian I was in I was fully in not like
you seen Bridget Everett's boobs I'm
sure that really connected you that was
the moment but for me like every single
woman on New York City housewives it has
the like the bang body like it's crazy
it's incredible it good for that yes
like I feel like there's just their
goals yes they're very much so goals
okay and now a few more Bravo
related questions first of all I have
this dream and I just want you to let me
know it's like I should keep dreaming or
like okay that Lala Kent will end up on
the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
that would be an amazing crossover I
think she'd have to be married first to
her boyfriend has anyone like taught any
whisperings no whisperings I mean that
would be really curious because she's so
much younger than all of them and like
Lisa knows how to like talk back to her
oh that's true I think I would be kind
of interesting and like if Erica Jean is
out lava is a young air she'd be like a
good replacement for okay keep dreaming
I I want you to keep going to put that
out that dream alive okay and now we
just need to talk about southern charm
reunion okay Catherine tweeted something
last night someone tweeted at her that
she should be the next Bachelorette for
the Bachelorette and she said I may or
may not be in talks have you heard
anything no I haven't but I'm
immediately going after this detects the
showrunner of the show who's my best
friend and and she's like Catherine's
best friend and I'm going to ask her
okay I will let you know immediately
okay I really clearly couette and you'll
tell me and I will literally do an
in-store E and I'll text you and I'll be
like it's confirmed its or it's denied
and I will do an end story until you
bring up a great that's right and she
needs she needs 25 men that she can
assess and as I said last time Catherine
really turned around this whole season
and she's really someone to look up to
and I'm like dead serious about me she
changed her whole life like she's in for
but like she's the mother that we all
wanted Catherine to be mm-hmm and wasn't
and now it's like as she's taken the
crazy role right so what's going on are
Ashley and Thomas going to be on next
season
I don't know because of all the rumors
about t Rav I think they're still in
talks about what's gonna happen you know
like he there was so many like sexual
assault cases that came out against him
if proven true there's just no way that
they would be on right cuz he would be
in the slammer he'd be in the slammer
and I don't think anyone wants to watch
like a [ __ ] no sexual assault abuser
guy but it did frustrate me that he
wasn't at the reunion because he needed
to be like held accountable not even for
all of the allegations against him cuz
he will have his day in actual court
yeah but for all of the things that he
did to Katherine and how he like
polluted the minds of everyone in the
group and bringing Ashley into the group
and how Ashley treated Katherine like I
just felt like he never had to he never
- owned up to any of his [ __ ] no and and
Ashley's like sort of taken that role
for him right and it's like Ashley is
not a worthy adversary no not at all and
she's because she's like little shield
that [ __ ]
yeah but Thomas I want him to like have
to explain an answer and and have the
one reunion where he goes through a
modicum of what Kathryn runs their
honoree I just want Andy there's like
all about for every little thing yeah
yeah that would be great that would be
great and I hope that one day that we
got that I'm literally going to ask my
best friend Morgan who sure wants the
show right now as soon as we get off and
I pee that's what I'm gonna be doing oh
my god amazing
yeah well text you keep us posted thank
you so much for joining are you kidding
thank you guys so much for having me
toasters you're my favorite fans of all
time thank you for coming over to team
Bethenny yeah I mean I've you've
converted me feel vindicated and I
understand like how it might have taken
you a while Carolyn is cool and she's
cool as a cucumber but she's a little
too cool now well we're gonna see who
replaces her this when how many more
episodes do you have before 3:00 Union
um the boat one was just the other day
so probably like three or four okay yeah
you're gonna see the Cabaret countess
cabaret count to some friends which is
great there's a lot to go down and the
reunion I think will probably be like
three parts I just watched the first
part the other day and it's great it's
amazing and you're patient or impatient
and I'm patient she's patient can't wait
this is I so much for tuning in we are
back tomorrow with snitch on the toast
she'll be co-hosting with me and then we
have guests Nastya you can so we'll be
taking all of your questions is that so
crazy that she's so talented
amazing we're just like hacks over here
but guys club uh thank you guys have a
great Q yay Thank You Dameron everyone
follow you at carpe Darren watch weekly
pregame on Sundays and my podcast
martinis and murder
you